جسم غريب يفرض حظرا جويا فوق مدينه
الروسيه الحكومه الامريكيه تحضر التيك توك
والصين ترد تقرير لجامعه تركيه يكشف
احتمال تكرار الزلزال المدمر
هذه الاخبار وغيرها لكم من قناه العربيه
اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
ونبدا من روسيا حيث تم فرض حظر جوي فيبقى
مدينه
البلاد بعد رصد جسم طائر مجهول في سماء
المدينه وفقا لتقارير محليه وكاله فنطانكا
الاعلاميه فيروسبورغ افادت بان الجسم
الطائر تسبب في وقف حركه الطيران فوق
المدينه وتعليق العديد من الرحلات لساعات
عده فيما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
لاحقا ان تدريبا جوي لطائراتها المقاتله
كان السبب وراء اغلاق المجال الجوي فوق
سنه بطرسبرج والدى الى تعليق حركه الطيران
امهل البيت الابيض على هيئه الحكوميه
ثلاثين يوما للتاكد من عدم وجود تطبيق تيك
توك الصيني على اي من الاجهزه او الانظمه
التابعه لها ووفقا لمذكره صادره عن مكتب
الاداره والميزانيه في البيت الابيض فان
على مختلف الوكالات والادارات والاجهزه
التابعه للحكومه الفيدراليه ازاله وحضره
تنزيل التطبيق على الاجهزه التي تملكها او
تديرها وان تمنع الاتصال عبر الانترنت بين
هذه الاجهزه والتطبيق وذلك بسبب مخاطر
التطبيق على الامن القومي الامريكي فيما
عبرت الخارجيه الصينيه عن رفضها لقرار
البيت الابيض
حذر تقرير جديد اصدرته جامعه التركيه من
احتمالات مرتفعه لوقوع المزيد من الزلازل
في ثلاث مناطق تقع جنوب وجنوب شرقي تركيا
بعد ان شهد زلزلين مدمرين خلال الشهر
الجاري
الذي اعده اعضاء هيئه التدريس المختصين
بعلم فيزياء الارض صنفوا خطوره الزلزال في
ولايات غازي عنتاب وملاطيا واديمن بانها
مرتفعه كما تطرق ايضا لمناطق اخرى صنفت
فيها احتمالات وقوع الزلزال بالعاليه جدا
كما هي الحال في ولايه انطاكيا مشيرا الى
ان هذه التحضيرات ستبقى قائمه لمده عامين
نتيجه الزلزلين الكبيرين الذين ضربات
البلاد
الى مصر هذه المره حيث اعلن احمد مرتضى
منصور عضو مجلس اداره الزمالك نقل والده
الى مستشفى السجن بعد تعرضه لوعكه صحيه
احمد قال في تصريحات الوسائل الاعلام
المحليه ان والده اصيب بارتفاع ضغط الدم
بجانب معاناته من مرض السكري مشيرا الى ان
حالته جيده الان وهناك تواصل مستمر معه
فيما صدر حكم القضاء مؤخرا برفض الطعن
المقدم من مرتضى منصور بخصوص الحكم الصادر
ضده بالحبس لمده شهر في قضيه سب وقذف
لرئيس نادي الاهلي محمود الخطيب
وفي خبرنا الاخير استعاد الملياردير ورجل
الاعمال الامريكيه لون ماسك مكانته كاغنى
شخص في العالم بعدما خسره لنحو شهرين مؤشر
وكاله بلومبرج الامريكيه للمليارديرات
اوضحها ان صافي ثروه ماسك بلغا
187.1 مليار دولار وكان ماسك المؤسس
المشارك لشركه تسلا للسيارات الكهربائيه
خسر نهايه العام 2022 المرتبه الاولى
كاغنى رجل في العالم لمصلحه نظيره
نتيجه انخفاض اسهم تسلا في فصل الشتاء
الماضي